Well, good morning church.
I hope that, uh, we can find a bit of refuge in this room,
maybe from the trials
and storms you face this week in life, uh, that we can
not get away from those fully,
but we can support each other in those.
And so we pray that that would be true for us today.
In fact, that's what we're gonna talk about,
the importance of the church.
So go ahead and take your copy of God's word
and turn with me
to first Timothy three, first Timothy three.
Maybe use your device.
You can, uh, scroll to that,
but to remember, if you have the app,
we have the sermon notes on there if you wanna take those
digitally or the paper copy of course as well.
But as you can see in our theological jar over the last
seven weeks, we have, uh,
been talking about the big rocks of our faith.
The first things first, foundational ideas
and beliefs, doctrines that make us distinctly Christian.
The core elements.
What what we're gonna do today is we're gonna shift to the
smaller rocks, the secondary issues,
some secondary second tier matters of our faith,
the smaller rocks that fit in around the big rocks,
which we put in first of course.
And we're only gonna look at one of those today of course,
and there's a lot more in there.
Don't think there are that many second tier issues in our
phase, just don't, it's just for illustration purposes.
Get that. Uh, but we're only gonna look at
one of those today.
There's, there's the idea again of how these fit in
around the big rocks.
And so you can see as I put this one in, it kind
of fits in some of the gaps there.
You can see that there's air underneath.
We can put some more rocks there and here.
And, and so that's the idea. We put the big rocks in first.
If we put the small rocks in first,
we can't fit the big ones in.
And so we put the big rocks first, the first things first,
and then we go from there with these second tier issues.
Now, what we're saying about these secondary issues,
what we mean with these are things that,
that believers differ on that create then different churches
or different denominations of churches.
Now, we're not saying that those people
who have different opinions on second tier issues,
we're not saying that those people are not believers
because if they have the same first tier big rock beliefs
and if they have the same core doctrines as we do, then,
then we would say they're also Christian.
But what we're talking about these smaller rocks are a few
things that cause a lot of heat
whenever they're debated things
that will have created significant boundaries that arise due
to interpretations of specific ways of handling church
and other things in our faith.
So lemme give you an example, help you understand
what we're talking about with second tier issues.
One example is the meaning and mode of baptism.
So some churches will baptize babies
because they see that as a sign of the covenant.
Like in the Old Testament circumcision, there's a sign
of the covenant and they're including that as a way
to illustrate the same kind of idea.
Well, we would differ on that
and say we're baptizing those who profess faith in Christ.
You have a a credible profession,
which is why we baptize no babies, but,
but people who can say, here's what I believe.
So there's a difference there, right? Here's another one.
Some people would say, some churches would say
that the main evidence that someone is saved,
that the Holy Spirit has come in their life, is that
that person would speak in unknown languages.
Well, we would differ and say that that's a spiritual gift
for some, that that's not the primary evidence
of everyone who's filled with the spirit of salvation.
So you can see why those differences would prevent us from
being together in the same local church.
Again, we're not saying they're not believers, we're saying
that there's a, a difference of the way that order
of services would go
or the way that we would be together in fellowship about how
to baptize certain people or not.
So that's why there's distinctions among churches
and these denominations.
And so we're gonna get to another one
of these smaller rocks today
as we look into one Timothy three,
we're gonna uncover ecclesiology.
Now, those did deal with the church as well,
but ecclesiology is simply a big word
that means the study of the church.
And so how to, how to handle it,
it's structure, it's purpose.
We're gonna see some distinctions we have as a church
that would differ from others in this second tier idea.
So first Timothy three,
we're gonna start in verse 14 for now.
I'm gonna read down through the verse 16 to start with.
I hope to come to you soon,
but I'm writing these things to you.
This is a personal letter, Paul to Timothy.
I'm writing these things to you so that if I delay,
you may know how one ought to behave in the household
of God, which is the church of the living God, a pillar
and buttress of the truth.
Great indeed, we confess is the mystery of godliness.
He was manifested in the flesh, vindicated by the spirit,
seen by angels proclaimed among the nations
believed on in the world taken up in glory.
God, we know this is your word.
Yes, Paul wrote this letter to Timothy,
but God we know that you included this for us today as well.
So give us eyes and ears to see
and hear what you want us to see and hear.
Give us hearts that are ready, good soil
to receive your word
and plant it deep into us that we bear good fruit
as a result of just talking about the church.
Or shape us into people who are not just hearers
of the word, but are doers of it as well for your glory
and our good others.
Good, thank you. In Jesus' name. Amen.
So this whole book of one Timothy is Paul,
the apostle Paul writing a training manual
to his protege Timothy,
who is a young pastor in a city called Ephesus in the Middle
East, uh, in Turkey these days.
But, but that's what he was writing was this entire letter
to say, here's here's what the church is,
here's how to handle the church.
Make sure you do it these ways.
But we need to back up a second
and ask even a fundamental question before we get to that.
What is the church like?
What even is the church
before we even talk about how
to structure it or how to handle it?
What even is it?
Well, that's why we started with these three verses
because the first thing we learn is that the true church,
the church is both truth and Christ based.
The church is both truth and Christ based.
That means it is founded on, as Ephesians two says,
on the truth, founded on the truth.
That's what he's meaning with this pillar and buttress idea.
We don't use that second word very often
and it doesn't mean that we're holding up the truth like
it's leaning on us, but again, we're founded on it
and we're charged with keeping it held fast.
So that's what a buttress does.
If you've never seen one before, it's meant
to like hold the wall up a little bit.
It's supporting it.
It doesn't mean it's the source,
it just means it's supporting.
So it's similar to our value as a church of anchoring truth,
where we talk about that in such a way that we are anchored
by the truth of God,
but then we're also to hold it fast in the winds of culture
that are blowing so strongly around us,
we're anchoring the truth as it needs to.
That's reflected here. Verse 16, he talks about, uh,
this familiar, probably at their time, familiar hymn,
maybe they were singing this or a creed.
They, they were reciting just to remind them of the truth
about Christ, right?
You saw that verse 16, he, that's Christ was
manifested in the flesh, visible, vindicated by the spirit,
proven seen by angels proclaimed among the nations,
believed on in the world, taken up in glory.
In some sense, that's like the foundational elements
of the gospel, the truth.
So he's going through, he's saying,
here's what the truth is.
You must base everything off of and it's about Christ.
And so this matters for us today in at least one way
that we need to understand any organization that would
call itself a church is lying
if it's not founded on the whole truth of God's word
with Christ as the cornerstone, right?
There's any organization can call themselves whatever they
want to unless it's based on the truth of God's word
and the cornerstone of Christ.
It's not a church. It may say it is, but it's not.
And we may, we must know that it's truth and Christ based.
That's what a church should be.
We can also look to the word itself, church
to help us understand a little bit of def definition.
What the church is. Now we're gonna put it on the screen.
It's in the original Greek language.
The word we know is church is eia.
Let's all practice our Greek together for a second.
You can see it right there. Eia, right?
All sound like scholars. That's great.
Um, you can see the little hyphen over the eye.
That means the emphasis is on that. Okay? Never.
We don't need to worry about that right now.
So, um, the word cia.
Now, you can't always take a Greek word and break it apart
and make it actually work, but in this case it does.
There's sometimes it doesn't.
But the word eck, the beginning, the the prefix eck, EK,
that means out of,
but then the root word of the cia, the rest of it kaleo.
In Greek, it means to call.
And so when you look at that word, it means
to us it's in English, it's church back then in Greek.
It means called out ones that that's
at the root of that word itself.
Called out ones when it's talking about the church.
Now remember what Paul was probably referring first
to here was the universal church or the invisible church.
Uh, we, we talk maybe about the global church,
but this is bigger than just where people are right now.
This is universal. Anybody who's ever believed in Christ is
part of this, usually capitalized.
See church, this universal invisible church,
all believers of all time.
That's yes, the church,
but he's also, since he's writing this
to Timothy in Ephesus, he's referring also
to the visible church that was Ephesus.
This is us here, the visible church.
A local expression of that universal global body.
Now it's a subset, yes,
but it's still a subset of the called out ones.
So that would be us.
Every church that is truth in Christ base is called out.
Ones called out as what called out
as a covenant community
before a covenant God, a relationship based on promises
from God to us that we can then return back
to him a covenant community
before a covenant God called out of the world,
made holy by God.
So much so that the New Testament calls us as believers,
saints not where you're gonna get your picture on the wall
and people are gonna like worship you.
No, not we're talking about that. We're talking about saints
in the biblical term where you are standing
before God, holy, righteous, clean.
That's the beauty of what he's done
to call us out of darkness.
Sin our shame our past called us out of that into something.
His community of saints, this is what he's done
for us, called out ones.
So those are helpful tools for us to understand.
Now, thankfully, God's word also gives us some metaphors,
some pictures to help us understand the
spiritual reality of the church.
Even better. One of them is right here in verse 15.
We read it a second ago.
What did it call us that you might ought to behave in the
what household of God.
So that's the first metaphor.
We're gonna look at this household of God.
Now wait a second, I just said the church is this global
entity, this empire that lasts beyond time.
And but no, no, actually it's also
a tight knit group bonded by familial ties.
Now I know the word family
conjuress up some pretty negative images
for some of us in this room right now.
And you've heard us say church family or family of God.
And that's a really negative thing in your life
because of the background you have
and experiences you've had,
which is why I think household may be a better term
because it gets away from some of the negativity of family
household, which is usually diverse when you look at that.
But, but the reality here,
we can't get away from the reality is that by faith
through the one spirit to the Father,
believers we are made to be children of God.
He is our father,
that we're brothers with Christ in a sense.
We're inheritance. His inheritance is ours.
We're heirs with Christ that that we are a part
of the household of God, the family of God that's pure
and right in the end.
How important is that image right now in a world
that's filled with loneliness division,
this, this is the place that we ought
to be able to love one another like true family.
That the lonely should
feel like they're a part of the family.
That the divisions
of the world should be just minimized here inside
because we're a family and we care
that deeply about each other, the household
of God.
Now here's the problem with that.
That means we can also wound one another like family.
But we must, when you think about the word fellowship,
the word koinonia is the original Greek word for that.
And there's so much more than just eating a meal together.
It's this in-depth connection that you have with people
who are not like you, but you love like family.
And there's true heart level
concern for each other.
This should be the family, the household of God.
Well that's not the only image.
There's a second image that we're gonna talk about today,
the temple of God.
The New Testament paints a picture of us
as the church being the temple of God.
Here's how Ephesians two says it, as Paul is referring
to the church and the unity between Jews and Gentiles
and how Christ is the foundation of that,
the cornerstone of that.
He says this Verse 21, in whom in Christ, the whole
structure being joined together
grows into a holy temple in the Lord.
So he's painting a picture of, of a building, right?
A physical building. He's looking at them at the people
and he's saying, you guys are
like the bricks of the building.
The stones one Peter two says the same thing.
You yourselves like living stones being built up
as a spiritual house to be a holy priesthood,
to offer spiritual sacrifices acceptable
to God through Jesus Christ.
That's all temple language.
This is where the worship happens.
This is is where the, the idea happens of, of responding
to God and meeting with God.
I mean, just think about the original temple.
What was it for by the way, that's not the original picture.
They didn't have cameras back then,
but that's just what we think it might've looked like.
That temple for those people back then was not just any old
building, it was the place
God's presence showed up.
It was the place they came to meet with God.
And if we are now called the temple of God together,
think about what that means.
It it means that, that
because God's spirit lives in us
individually as believers.
Then when we come together, one Corinthians says,
when we come together in a unique
and special way, God is with us
and his presence is among us.
We are the temple that we
don't have to go to a building anymore.
The people, we are his dwelling place.
In fact, I love what one Corinthians 14 says about that.
See one Corinthians 14 is talking about order of services
and how, like how the chaos of this could get to that.
And he's just saying, no, we need to be, we need
to be ordered in things.
But he says this in an interesting way.
Paul writes where he says, the way we worship
as believers, the way we interact together
as believers should lead someone who's an outsider.
It says, somebody who's new walks in the room,
walks into the body together
and says, God is truly among you
that the way those people were worshiping,
the way we should be worshiping as the temple of God,
the way we should be interacting together
as priests in the temple of God says to someone who walks in
who has no idea and they walk in
and say, wow, God is
among this group of people.
God is truly here.
Can we be praying for that?
That someone who has no other connection walks in
and says, I, I feel I sense God is among you
merely because of the way we worship, the way we interact.
Let's pray for that. The temple of God.
Here's the third one. We are called the people
of God in the New Testament,
the church is the people of God.
This is one Peter two, nine
and 10 says, you are a chosen race, a royal priesthood,
a holy nation, a people for his own possession
that you may proclaim the excellencies of him
who called you out of darkness into his marvelous light
once you were not a people, but now you are God's people.
Once you had not received mercy,
but now you have received mercy.
What Peter's doing is he's calling back to the exodus,
remember where God redeemed Israel out of slavery in Egypt?
What did he redeem them out for? Just to give them freedom.
No. Exodus six, seven, God says, I will take you
to be my people and I will be your God.
You shall know that I'm the Lord your God
who brought you out from under the burdens of the Egyptians.
That same phrase is repeated over and over
and over in the Old Testament till finally,
Peter picks it up in one Peter two
and says, those who believe are the ones
who are God's people, those who have been called out
of darkness of sin
and shame into his marvelous light,
freed from slavery into freedom.
You are his people now. You are God's people.
And listen, when we talk about being God's people,
we're talking about a new nation.
We're talking about something
that supersedes every other relational tie, family tie,
national tie that we may have here.
The kingdom of God is a new nation, a new people
that supersedes all of it because it lasts eternally.
And because it goes to all the nations,
not just this one we live in,
we must not allow anyone to doubt
where our true allegiance lies.
We still live here. We still have responsibilities.
But remember, we're a part of something that is internal.
We're a part of a people that are eternal.
Which by the way, that's Revelation 21.
Verse three says, talking about the end,
listen to what this says.
I heard a loud voice from the throne saying,
behold the dwelling place of God is with mankind.
He will dwell with them and they will be his people.
That's not the nation idea.
This is a new eternal group of people
that supersedes everything else we're tied to here.
Our true allegiance is there.
The people, the people of God
we're called the flock of God as well.
This passage, uh, in one Peter five talking to pastors,
he refers to twice the flock talking about the church.
So he's referring to the local church
where Christ is the chief shepherd, of course.
But that still means we're all part of God's flock.
We're part of this flock and part of God's flock.
And and what that means.
If we are sheep as a part of a flock, that means some things
that we're messy, we're noisy.
We're often confused like these sheep seem to be right now.
We even bite each other at times.
But also think about what the flock
has as the flock of God.
We have a good shepherd who lays his life down
for his sheep, who protects us,
who surrounds us, who goes
after the one leaves, the nine nine and goes
after the one who wandered off.
So to be the flock, yes, that's humbling that we're sheep,
but it's also good news that we've got
this shepherd that we do.
So we're the flock of God.
And there's many other images
of scripture showing us the church.
But I wanna highlight one more,
that the church is the body of Christ.
This may be one of the most familiar ones.
The body of Christ, one Corinthians 12 is
so detailed about this interconnectedness of the body,
how important it is for each part of the body and,
and how Christ is the head of the body.
But we are all a part of the body and
and we inherently understand this metaphor.
So I wanna give you some time
to engage with this for a second.
So reach down and whether it's a Bible or a pen
or a cup of coffee or whatever, it's just pick something up.
Just hold it. Just reach down, pick something up.
Now I, I want you to think for a second
how much was involved in you just doing that One thing,
you didn't think about it when you were doing it
'cause it's just part of what your body does.
But think about the muscles had to work,
the bone structure had to hold your muscles up.
The nerves had to fire in that the, the eyes had
to look about what you're going to pick up.
Your nerves fired, then your heart was pumping blood through
that to your lungs.
Were oxygenating your blood so it works, right?
You could go on and on, right?
All just to pick up your Bible or a pen or whatever else.
And so we get this, we inherently understand this metaphor
that each body part has a role to play
that if they don't, the rest of the body's hindered.
We understand that when you're injured, the body can't do
what it's supposed to do.
Just think about that. If we as the church are the body
of Christ, Christ is the head, we are then his hands,
feet, body, are you that connected
with other parts of the body
where you feel if someone doesn't
or if they, they feel if you don't perform
what you're supposed do, are you that connected?
Are you serving others and allowing them to serve you?
Are you, are you giving generously to support other parts
of the body financially when they're in need?
Are you grieving with those who grieve
as one Corinthians 12 talks about that you feel it when
somebody's hurting or you're rejoicing when someone is
honored, even if it means you're not getting
honored, they're getting honored.
The body is getting honored by that
Christ is receiving the glory that,
and you're rejoicing with.
Are you that connect? Please listen.
So much of church life in the last
50 years in America has been this disconnected entity
where we come, we sit, we listen, we leave.
If we're the body of Christ, there's so much more to it.
Now I, I share these five metaphors for a reason
because I know I'm prone to this.
We tend to think in one
or two of those metaphors about the church.
We pick our favorite and we
say, well, we're the body of Christ.
Or we pick that we're the flock
and we're just sheep like that.
We kind of land in one or two of those.
So we have to deliberately move our minds to the others
because we have a, we need to have a biblical understanding
of the church, right?
We might have forgotten some of these truths
that we're the people of God, there's a new nation.
We have allegiances, right?
You can see how this can help us
understand the church better.
So that's the nature of the church.
But then we, we need to know what the church's structure is.
That's the next piece of this.
As we talked about these smaller rocks getting into that,
what is the church's structure,
this local expression, how do we structure it?
Well, it varies. And if you've been in church most
of your life, you know that there's a variety of ways
that people structure churches.
Some churches have one pastor and a board of deacons.
Some churches have an outside group overseeing the church.
Some churches have women pastors. We don't. Others don't.
Some churches have elders that are boards, elders
that are council elders that are involved
on staff non-Stop you.
You see how there's a lot of variety.
We could go even further than that.
That's why there's more than one church in a city, right?
That's why there are different interpretations leading
to different denominations.
We differ on these and other smaller rock items now.
Now again, if they are core big rock people with us,
we're on the same team.
If they hold the same core doctrines,
same basic beliefs, they're Christian too.
Like I'm, I'm so thankful
for churches like Faith Bible Church and Bridgeway
and First Assembly
and these others that are faithfully
believing the same things.
We believe about the core doctrines,
yet we differ on some of the other stuff.
They're different than we are.
Yes, but we're on the same team with those
who are believers as well.
Yes, we're not competing against anybody remember that.
But how do we do it here? What's our distinctive structure?
Well, we get it in part from one Timothy three.
So I skipped the first 13 verses.
We're gonna go back and read those now.
This is part of where we get a glimpse of our structure.
So one Timothy three starting in verse one.
Now the saying is trustworthy.
If anyone aspires to the office of overseer,
he desires a noble task.
Therefore an overseer must be above reproach.
The husband of one wife, sober-minded, self-controlled,
respectable, hospitable, able to teach, not a drunkard,
not violent, gentle, not quarrelsome, not a lover of money.
He must manage his own household well with all dignity,
keeping his children submissive.
For if someone does not know how to care,
manage his own household, he,
how will he care for God's church?
He must not be a recent converter.
He'll become puffed up with conceit, falling
to the condemnation of the devil.
Moreover, he must be well thought of by outsiders so
that he may not fall into disgrace,
into a snare of the devil.
Deacons likewise must be dignified, not double tongue,
not addicted to much wine nor greedy for dishonest gain.
They must hold the mystery of the faith
with a clear conscience.
Let them be tested first. Let them serve as deacons.
If they prove themselves blameless, their wives
likewise must be dignified, not slanderous,
sober minded, faithful in all things.
Let deacons each be the husband of one wife
managing their children and their households well for those
who serve well as deacons gain a good standing
for themselves and also great confidence in the faith
that is in Christ Jesus.
And so you saw in just that little section,
two distinct offices of the church, right?
Overseers and deacons, it's the same thing, Paul,
when he is writing to the Philippians, he says in verse one,
Paul and Timothy, servants of Christ
to all the saints in Christ Jesus who are at Philippi
with the overseers and deacons.
So that's partly where we get our structure from.
Now we say there are two offices.
I, I'm gonna articulate four,
but you'll see why there's still really only two.
The first we would say is
that Christ is the head of the church.
No matter what structure you should have
or would have, Christ is the head he rules over the church.
And by the way, he's the only one who can fill that office.
So it's not any rotation. He is theirs.
That's why it's not really technically an office
for us because he's there.
He's never changing. But then second, you saw it here,
that overseers.
Now there's a lot of words in scripture used
about leaders in the church.
Elders, pastors, shepherds, overseers.
We see those as pretty much synonymous
that he's referencing people who are in
that position, that office.
So these are the servant leaders
of the church, which we believe.
Side note that there's a, a plurality
of those when we see it in the New Testament.
Meaning I'm one of your pastors, we have more than one.
We believe that's a healthy, safe structure
for us and for the church.
But we see that in scripture, a plurality
of elders in a local church.
That was the second group. Now there's a third group,
deacons, which we would call the leading servants
of the church where they are to assist the pastors.
They're there to, uh,
meet practical needs within the church.
See that Acts chapter six, all over scripture as well.
Now, as a side note, I want you to to remember when we read
that in one Timothy three, I hope you saw it.
The primary qualification for elders
and deacons is character.
It's not wealth, it's not influence,
it's not knowledge, it's integrity.
It's character that supersedes every ability
or every resource anybody has.
It's that first.
But then there's a fourth group of people in the church,
Philippians one, one called 'em,
the saints one Peter five, the flock.
This is us, all of us
that we the congregation are really the final
governing authority in the church.
But also we have responsibilities within the church.
We are not just sit back and receiving passively.
We are a part of the body
to serve the rest of the body.
And so again, I'm just going through basic structure here.
You can see how these small rock things create churches
and denominations that we differ on the
interpretation of some of those things.
But I don't wanna just focus on distinctions today.
So here's what we're gonna end with.
What is the church's task?
Okay, we saw like
what the church is structure, those kinda things.
What, what is the church's task?
Let's, let's focus on what we are to do.
Remember, this is not just a social club,
not just a service organization.
What is the church to do?
Here's three tasks I believe every church ought to be about.
First one, worship God.
The first worship God from the very beginning.
The community of God's people.
Remember out of Egypt, I called you.
Why did he call them to worship him?
He told Pharaoh that I'm calling my people out, freeing them
so they can come worship me In the wilderness,
we are called out ones to worship.
That's why our primary task is to lift his name high,
to glorify him, to declare his majesty
and to declare our allegiance to him above all else.
That's worship. Worship is not just singing.
Worship is us responding to who he is and what he's done.
Now we do that through singing.
We do that through the Lord's supper, through baptisms,
through giving financially.
We do that through hearing his word,
responding to it, right?
That's all worship. The worship service
is every part of it.
From the time we start until the time we walk out the door.
And I would even say even stuff out there is worship.
As you're fellowing and, and talking
and challenging and encouraging.
It's not just worship when we sing,
but that also means, listen, we shouldn't wash,
we shouldn't walk in here primarily for us,
what we can get out of this.
I mean, I've heard people say, oh,
I didn't get much outta worship today.
Well that's, that's okay because it wasn't for you.
We're here for him, right?
Like we, we walk in here to offer offerings of praise
to our God who has saved us.
And so we receive reciprocal benefit from that. Yes.
But it's primarily because we want to lift him up
and glorify him above all else.
What does he receive out of it?
That should be our primary goal.
So worship God, that's number one. We do that.
Second, the church's task is to nurture believers.
What is the church to do? Just base level worship.
God nurture believers.
This is what Ephesians four says about that.
About how church leaders we are to equip the saints
for the work of ministry, for building up the body of Christ
until we all attain to the unity of the faith
and the knowledge of the Son of God.
To mature manhood to the measure,
the stature of the fullness of Christ.
So that we may no longer be children. There's growth, right?
Tossed to and fro by the waves
and carried about by every wind of doctrine, human cunning,
craftiness and deceitful schemes.
Rather speaking the truth in love.
We are to grow up in every way into him.
Who is the head into Christ? From whom?
The whole body joined
and held together by every joint with which it is equipped.
When each part is working properly, makes the body grow so
that it builds itself up in love.
Listen, I'm not finished growing yet.
You're not finished growing yet.
None of us look like Christ yet as we one day will.
But until that day comes, God uses the church
to help us get there.
Lemme just think about this as believers.
What brothers and sisters hold me accountable.
That helps me grow. Somebody teaching
you how to obey God's word.
Helping you grow sin.
When it's repented of shown grace to, it grows
as we serve one another with the gifts we've been given.
We grow as we give financially to care for each other.
We grow as we encourage, as we equip, we're helping grow
as we do all of that,
what we're doing is we're helping each other conform
to the image of God's son to Christ.
Like this. Nearly all
of the New Testament letters were written to churches
and their primary concern was
how those believers were growing.
Paul's like, man, how, how's it going?
Tell me, here's what I hope happens for you.
Here's the growth I want in you. Those kind of things.
And in that, there is no category in God's word
for someone to sit in a church year after year after year
and never grow in their faith.
Never grow in obedience to Christ. You just can't find it.
It's not there. That just does not happen.
If the Lord is truly working
in someone's life, it doesn't happen.
Now, I'm not saying it's gonna be a perfectly upward slope
of your growth path
'cause mine's not mine looks more like this, right?
Kind of just doing this all.
But the the general trend
over time is christlikeness.
Eventually one day he's gonna complete the work.
He began in me. And you know what he did to get me there?
He used the church. He uses the church.
People within the church structure to get me down the road.
I'm not where I need to be yet,
but praise God, I'm not where I was.
And the church is what God uses towards that end.
And so we are to nurture believers, help each other grow.
Here's the third one. We are to live sent
worship God nurture believers live sent,
hear this all the time around here.
Christ's final words to his disciples
and by extension to us were to go make disciples
of all nations to be witnesses locally and globally.
That's what he left with them.
And then the entire book of Acts, Christ ascended to heaven.
The Spirit descended on the church.
The entire book of Acts is the story
of God's mission expanding
through his people, through the church.
Why do we somehow think that we're not included in that?
That's what he does through the church,
is he sends his people and listen.
Some people try to pit those three tasks against each other.
Like we gotta pick one
or the other at the expense of those others.
No, we can be about all three
of those at the same time, can't we?
It's a both end. It's not an either or.
We can worship God as we worship God.
People are drawn to something bigger than ourselves.
They walk in God's truly among you.
Something's happening here.
As we grow in our faith, we see we wanna worship more.
We wanna go more because we see the importance of it
as we go and follow our shepherd into the world,
it stretches us, it nurtures us,
and it creates dependence on God.
'cause we can't do it ourselves. And you think,
just think about the times you've seen God work in your life
and other people's lives around the baptism stories we've
heard and we see lives transformed.
We see marriages healed. We see people freed from addiction.
Does that not spur worship as we see God work
through us going, it all ties together.
See friends, this is the church. This is the church.
An imperfect, messy group of people
who are trusting in a perfect and secure God.
What glory he gets when he uses people like us. When.